المراسل المخضرم جيرارد ريال هو
المدير في icij حيث قاد
فريق الصحفيين العالميين الذين كسروا
قصة ورق الباندورا الذي انضم إليّ الآن
من واشنطن جيرارد ، مرحبًا بكم في
البرنامج ، ومن الواضح أن هذه
التقارير المفاجئة أدت إلى أصداء في
جميع أنحاء العالم.  بيان
من الحكومة في الأردن ، لكن دعني
أطلب منك تفصيلها
لجمهورنا الذي تعرف أن البنوك في
جوارها لديها حساب مصرفي واحد
وهذا كل شيء ولا
تفهم ما يكشفه هذا التحقيق ،
هل يمكنك تفصيله لنا؟  بالنسبة
لنا ولهم
جيدًا ، نتحدث عن 11 أو ما يقرب من 12
مليون مستند من الأمم بشكل أساسي
من الأشخاص الذين أنشأوا حسابات
ومدخرات ضريبية خارجية إذا ذهبت إلى الخارج
بهذه الطريقة فأنت تعمل بشكل فعال
خارج المعايير العادية للتمويل
يمكنك  العب بشكل أساسي في
عالم مواز وما نراه
هنا ونحن نعمل مع 600
صحفي من أكثر من 100
دولة مختلفة 150 د  مؤسسات إعلامية غير مألوفة
بما في ذلك الخط الأمامي
وموقع واشنطن هنا في
الولايات المتحدة وكشفنا بشكل أساسي عن
أسرار الأشخاص الموجودين في السلطة
بشكل أساسي الأشخاص الذين كانوا
يقولون لسنوات أن هذا نظام
لا يخدم حقًا  أي هدف حقيقي حقيقي
، ومع ذلك
فنحن نرى أنهم هم أنفسهم
يستفيدون منه ، نعم لقد كشفت
عن ملفات نتحدث فيها عن 12
مليون ملف مالي لأكثر من 330
سياسيًا من 90 دولة
ويجب أن يقال هذا كله  قانوني ،
كيف يكون هذا قانونيًا وكيف
تمكنوا من الاستفادة من هذه
الثغرات
جيدًا إذا ذهبت إلى الخارج ، يمكنك
أساسًا إنشاء شركة
تسمح لك بالعمل في الخفاء بالكامل تقريبًا
ما لم يحدث شيء مثل
هذا بالطبع وحصل الصحفيون على
الاحتفاظ بالمعلومات وما نراه
هنا هو حقًا أسرار هؤلاء
الأشخاص الأقوياء من جميع هذه
البلدان المختلفة وقد يكون الأمر
قانونيًا عندما  نشرنا لأول مرة تحقيقًا سابقًا
يسمى أوراق بنما التي
كان يقولها الناس في ذلك الوقت كان
كل هذا قانونيًا وبالطبع منذ ذلك الحين تم استرداد أكثر
من 1.4 مليار دولار من الضرائب المتأخرة
ودخل الكثير من الأشخاص
إلى السجن نتيجة لذلك.
أعتقد أن الوقت سيحدد ما إذا كان
كل شيء نراه هنا قانونيًا أم لا ،
لكن أعتقد من الآن أن ما
نراه هو بالتأكيد أسئلة طُرحت
نعم ، وبالنسبة لأولئك الذين يشاهدون في المنزل ،
أنا متأكد من أن الكثيرين يمكنهم تذكر ذلك
التحقيق  من أوراق بنما
في عام 2016 وكان ذلك أمرًا يسقط في
حد ذاته وما هو مثير للاهتمام للقراءة
في هذا التقرير الجديد هو أن الدروس تم
تعلمها بالتأكيد من أوراق بنما
ولكن ربما لا تكون بالضرورة
الدروس الصحيحة لأن العديد من هؤلاء
الأفراد وأولئك الذين
تساعدهم بما في ذلك المحامين على مضاعفة جهودهم
في جعل
متابعة الأموال أكثر صعوبة بسبب عدم وجود عبارة أفضل
، ربما يستحق الأمر الإشارة إلى
في أوراق بنما كان يعتمد على
مزود خدمة خارجي واحد فقط في بنما
وهو ما أدى إلى الأسماء هنا ،
نحن نبحث عن 14 مقدم خدمة مختلفًا
في ولايات قضائية متعددة
حول العالم وما نراه
هنا بعد أوراق بنما التي قاموا بها
أصبحنا أكثر تعقيدًا حول
كيفية إخفاء أصولهم وكيفية قيامهم بأعمال
تجارية ونحن نشهد نوعًا من
المحادثات المرحة حول
كيف لا يريدون حدوث أوراق بنما أخرى
، ومع ذلك لدينا هنا
أوراق باندورا التي أقولها كثيرًا  أكبر ،
لذا فإن هذا كله عاهر
وسندخل في بعض التفاصيل في
لحظة ولكن هل يمكنك أن تشرح لماذا
في رأيك ليس هذا
ضارًا للعالم فحسب ، بل إنه شيء
يجب أن يدركه المشاهدون
جيدًا على ما أعتقد  أهم شيء
بالنسبة للشخص العادي هو أنه لا يمكنك القيام
بذلك إذا
كنت شخصًا عاديًا ، فلن
يكون لديك الموارد
أو
التطور لتتمكن من القيام بذلك ،
ومع ذلك فإن هؤلاء الأشخاص الأقوياء
من تعرف أن أحد
أهم الأشياء التي نتجت عن
ذلك هو نفاق هؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين كانوا يقولون لسنوات أن هذا
شيء لا ينبغي أن يحدث
وأن تقاريرنا
تتحدث عن كلماتهم في ذلك الوقت  والآن ما
نراه في الوثائق لذا أعتقد أن
أهم شيء هنا هو
نفاق قادتنا